[Music]
soprano Heather Inger Breton from the us
singing from Mozart's opera the
abduction from the seraglio and
Christina mycket Aryan another one of
the eleven artists at this year's bond
or Prague are born in southern Russia
christina began her career at the
Bolshoi Theatre in Moscow since then she
sang on the greatest operatic stages in
the world Sonja would have been added
today I'll sing Gilda's aria from
Rigoletto an aria from mass news man oh
and my favorite duet parody Okara from
Verdi's La Traviata
Tavia theme is nice to a public coach in
the audience loves Childers Aria and
Meno is my favorite singing is great for
the sword
[Music]
all of the artists offered their
services for free on this special
evening all for a good cause
[Music]
I thought of kibosh nights
aids is a very important topic not only
for Russia and Germany but for the
entire world this disease unites us in
certain ways just as music unites us the
music gives us the strength to work
together to combat the disease bombs
charity Opera Gala is one of the
highlights on the social calendar in the
former German capital the proceeds go to
the German aids foundation which mainly
supports research projects because
despite medical advances AIDS remains
incurable the gala was initiated by
aren't and Helmut andreas heart fish the
pair have organized the event for eight
years now opera is about the biggest
feelings lab desire and passion and the
disease encompasses those feelings too
so that's why this garlic combines that
also successfully and we say be joyful
have fun but also do something good
combining these two things is something
opera can do this year a non singer
participated for the first time Thomas
Paul Harvey the young hungarian is one
of the most creative and innovative
trumpet players of his generation
[Music]
I also felt like an honor to be invited
to to perform with singers because as a
as a trumpet player and I think also I
can say as other instrumentalists we
would like to play as beautiful as the
singers can sing the gamma rays 230,000
euros this year
a new record and so the bomb opera gala
remains a winning ticket of art glamour
and charity on the Rhine
you